maintenant aujourd'hui au qu'on aille on
n'est pas rassuré dans le métro par tous
donc voilà ça m'étonne pas mais quand on
a des enfants mais maintenant on fait
super attention fermées portes qu'on
fait voilà fait super attention le choc
à la verrière après l'arrestation ce
mercredi matin de cet homme de 22 ans
alexandre d'aussi suspecté d'être
l'agresseur au cutter d'un militaire à
la défense le 25 mai placé en garde à
vue il a rapidement reconnu les faits
mais l'enquêté ne fait que commencer
le parquet et la police judiciaire ont
considéré que cet homme était
suffisamment dangereux parfois pour le
placer sous l'autorité pour placer cette
enquête sous l'autorité du parquet
antiterroriste
et pour mener une action qui a conduit à
son arrestation à son interpellation
ce matin c'est grâce à ces images
provenant d'une caméra de surveillance
mais aussi à des traces d'adn retrouvées
sur une bouteille d'eau oublier que son
arrestation a été rendue possible aux
alentours de 6 heures du matin l'homme
s'était installée depuis quelques mois à
la verrière dans le quartier du bois de
l'étang
originaire du perray-en-yvelines c'est
un désaccord avec sa famille sur sa
conversion un islam radical qui l'aurait
poussé à quitter le domicile
même les gens du quartier ne trouvais un
peu bizarre parce qu'il était un peu des
fois on le voyait à la mosquée mais d'un
autre côté il était à y puiser un peu
d'alcool donc il cherche et je pense que
c'est il faut pas faire l'amalgamme
c'était pas un bon musulman ce n'est pas
un vrai musulman parce qu'on a appelée
mosquée du coin n'y a pas de personnes
qui endoctrinent je pense qu'il s'était
vraiment une personne isolée
c'est un fait isolé et personnes là se
chercher et elle a fait ça peut-être
pour pas peur aux hauts faits de londres
et voulait faire une concurrence je n'ai
pas la moindre idée chère explications
mais celui pour donner à l'association
des musulmans de la verrière et le maire
10 rejetées avec force et fermeté les
agissements de celui qui aujourd'hui
devra répondre d'actes de terrorisme et
qui était jusque là connu des services
de police pour plusieurs vols
on va communiquer on va essayer de
mettre bien la distance nécessaire entre
l'événement et la ville parce qu'il ya
une vraie distance entre l'événement
et on va on va rassurer notre population
va rassurer les communautés pour leur
dire que nous continuons notre travail
d'accompagnement de soutien et que tous
ensemble nous démarquons évidemment de
ce type d'actes qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être dans notre commune comme sur
notre territoire
le militaire blessé au cou a retrouvé sa
famille depuis lundi avec une incapacité
totale de travail de 10 jours